il est en course pour devenir l'arbre de
l'année 2020 ce cèdre bleu de l'atlas
enraciné dans le centre hospitalier
théophile roussel de montesson fait
partie des quatorze finalistes nationaux
cet arbre qui mesure 12 mètres d'eau a
été planté avant la seconde guerre
mondiale dans le parc de cette ancienne
maison de correction pour garçons il a
vu passer des générations d'enfants en
90 ans d'existence
ils ont profité de cet art où ils ont vu
cet art où ils ont sûrement confier des
secrets ils ont grimpé dans l'arbre
c'est un lieu de vie de passage on vient
s'y promener on vient s'y ressource et
on vient peut-être raconter des choses à
cet arbre voilà c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
lancé dans cette aventure du concours de
l'arbre de l'année
cette histoire a séduit le jury
aujourd'hui le site est devenu un
établissement de santé mentale et
l'arbre a vu les années défilent et il
porte sur son tronc et ses branches les
stigmates du temps conséquences du gel
et des sécheresses d'une mini tornade en
encore de la fameuse tempête de 1999 il
a perdu au moins cinq matches au niveau
de la sim
quand il ya eu la tempête et donc
intentions may 12 mètres 50 au lieu
d'être presque 18 mètres qu'il avait au
départ avec une circonférence que l'on a
pu mesurer que les services techniques
et espaces verts de trois mètres
cinquante de circonférence
il est comme tout à chacun il a subi les
affres de la vie pour autant il en sort
peut-être plus fort mais il est toujours
là il est fort il est central
il fait partie voilà de notre quotidien
le cèdre bleu compte à ce jour plus de
1250 signature il est pour l'instant
sixième position sur 14
si vous voulez le soutenir vous pouvez
voter jusqu'au 5 janvier